housing developers offer all kinds of
benefits to try to entice buyers but the
latest trend in real estate goes beyond
the normal perks its homes and
neighborhoods designed to support the
physical and spiritual well-being of
residents so how can a property purchase
reduce stress improve health and bring
peace of mind Manuel Bojorquez visited a
planned development or in Orlando
Florida to find out for the foot family
everyday can feel like a vacation with
time for six-year-old Charlie and
eight-year-old Jacob to splash around at
the pool and play at the park I lived
about 10 minutes away from here we
didn't know our neighbors and I had two
little boys and I wanted them to play
and to socialize and I never I never
found that so when I looked for a new
house I said to my husband I really want
a place that has a community feel the
place Natalia and her husband Michael
decided on was Lake Nona in Orlando one
of the latest successes in wellness real
estate the entire 17 square mile
development is designed to optimize
healthy living through amenities and
events how do you think life would have
been for you your husband and the boys
had you not moved here I definitely
wouldn't have had free yoga I probably
wouldn't have been open to meditation
the boys it wouldn't be as easy to just
have ready made friends here yoga and
meditation classes are free and
community events ranging from gardening
to live music encourage neighbors to
bond there are many communities where
people don't know their neighbors right
right we're on I don't know a thousand
events a year right that's how we make a
difference here in terms of the
collaboration is by getting people
together providing a venue for people to
do that and then the people do all the
work Tavistock development company
president James Burrell says 14,000
residents have moved into these homes
which can be customized to improve
health
[Music]
eally 11 percent of residents work in
the community at what's become known as
a Medical City these 650 acres are home
to two hospitals to university campuses
and biomedical research facility
as opposed to a traditional community
where you build the houses and then you
get the school and then you get the
hospital this is in many ways the
reverse of that yeah we had a golf
course but it was pretty you know modest
in the grand scale of this whole place
and then we got jobs and we had these
institutions come and then we went into
more housing and now we're actually
focused on the retail so one of our big
things right now is creating this town
center and a retail environment and as
part of the point there to just give
also people a place where they can walk
to the store to the restaurant and not
getting a car necessarily a hundred
percent what we call that walkability is
a neo urban environment so a new urban
environment it's kind of the best of
urban with suburban it's a lot easier to
work from home when your child is going
to daycare across the street for nearly
a quarter of residents the stress of
commuting is non-existent they work from
home thanks in part to gigabit internet
with speeds 200 times faster than the
average u.s. household you can go to
school here from pre-k all the way to
graduate school without leaving the
property in public education there's
jobs here you know there's great housing
choices from you know apartments you
know all the way through to
multi-million dollar houses so you know
there really is something really here
for everybody most people think of
Orlando they think theme parks and lakes
are you looking to rebrand the city in a
way in any place especially like Orlando
that's the most visited place on the
globe this success becomes you know
something that sometimes can overshadow
other things so so we're not looking to
take away from any of that I think what
we're doing is we're working on you know
the other part the second half of the
story which is the university education
jobs families like the foots are
participating in a multi-generational
study that looks at the benefits of
active lifestyles that may be part of
the reason Lake Nona has gotten
endorsements from some big names in the
health and wellness realm well-being is
the number one trend in the world it
correlates with everything that happens
in society including crime rates and
quality of leadership and social unrest
integrative medicine pioneer Deepak
Chopra often visits the
munity for a Health Forum that brings
industry leaders together each year he
also offers a customized version of his
health app to Lake Nona residents we are
creating a city or a community of
well-being and this is happening now
it's futuristic but I think this will be
the trend everywhere soon according to
the global wellness Institute the
International wellness real estate
industry was valued at 134 billion
dollars last year the US has been a
pioneer with over 350 communities that
revolve around reducing stress the
industry will likely grow to 180 billion
dollars globally by 2022 this is
something that where we invite companies
to come here with Jim spore leading the
way Lake Nona is cashing in on the trend
that soon to be built town center will
boast 4 million square feet of shopping
hotels entertainment and commercial
space for the foot family it's all the
more reason to make themselves at home
I love living here I love it and I know
it's been three and a half years but I
still walk around and I say wow this is
the community we live in we live here
and I'm very grateful for it for CBS
this morning Saturday and while
Bojorquez Orlando so what do you think
Elena you move in you know what it is
such an ambitious project but we always
hear about the importance of habits so
here you have a place where they're
trying to think about how can we make
people's habits healthier encourage good
gonna be interesting to see them
although I'm in New Yorker I get
stressed when it gets me quiet you're
probably not the typical no I'm not your
target customer